[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire rugby les
phases de poule de division honneur se
sont terminées ce week-end coup de
projecteur sur la saison du sky rugby le
club termine en milieu de tableau à la
7e place du classement nous recevrons
des membres du club dans cette émission
football des jeunes
zibeline aura été ce week-end à
clairefontaine pour participer à la
danone nations cup l'un des plus grands
tournois au monde pour les joueurs âgés
de 10 à 12 en reportage à suivre pour le
rock et dans le championnat de nationale
iv les chocs se terminent leur saison de
la plus belle des manières en s'imposant
sur un score large contre asnières le
résumé du match dans cette émission
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
du rugby pour commencer ce 7,8 sport
dans le championnat de division honneur
versailles a réussi son pari déjà
assurés de la montée les hommes de la
cité royale terminent la phase de poule
invaincu 18 matchs et 18 victoires les
verseille se sont largement imposés 57 à
22 sur le terrain du skiff
une victoire qui leur permet de terminer
la saison avec 84 points 21 points de
plus que leur dauphin paris15 versailles
tentera maintenant de remporter le
championnat de france toujours en rugby
est toujours dans le championnat honneur
le ska rugby termine sa saison sur une
mauvaise note
les saint quentinois se sont inclinés
lors de l'ultime journée contre
ministère finance paris sur le score de
29 à 10 le sky et termine donc à la 7e
place du championnat pour nous parler de
cette saison nous recevrons sur ce
plateau le président guillaume payen
l'entraîneur thomas païens et l'ailier
jérémy barbier bonsoir bonsoir
alors on vous attendait sur ce plateau
avec une victoire guillaume qu'est ce
qui s'est passé n'a pas réussi à gagner
on aurait bien voulu gagner pourtant
effectivement tué sept c'était une
dernière un dernier match et une défaite
mais quelques-unes avant malheureusement
mes ouailles herbe enfin on va fé
constat avec les joueurs qu'on avait
tout donné donc de ce point de vue là
bas pas de frustration
fait ce qu'on pouvait et à 20 minutes de
la fin on était à égalité et on a craqué
à la fin donc physiquement n'a pas
réussi à tenir tout le match on l'a
perdu
l'équipe adverse avait un enjeu fort
puisqu'il veut le maintien en fait
absolument qu'ils gagnent et et donc ils
ont tout donné nous on a été sur un
match où on avait plus de places à
gagner au classement juste à essayer de
bien finir on n'a pas réussi
vous l'avez pris un petit peu à la
légère tourne à peut-être ce match non
pas du tout pas du tout c'est un match
qu'on a appris avec beaucoup de sérieux
et on a bien travaillé toute la semaine
c'était un match qui marqua ce la fin
d'un cycle aussi avec des joueurs comme
jérémy carette leur orchestre sur ce sur
ce match donc le groupe voulait faire un
bon résultat après il était peut-être
plus en forme vous avez peut-être plus
de d'énergie peut-être que cela vient
aussi de l'enjeu parce que en effet il
veut leur maintien sur cette dernière
partie mais du coup du coup nous on l'a
préparé beaucoup de sérieux on a tout
donné mais on est tombé sur une super
équipe qui nous a mis en difficulté
jérémy comment vous l'avez ressenti
cette dernière sur la pelouse
bah écoutez moi déjà j'étais dans les
tribunes est-ce que j'ai été suspendu
sur le match précédent
après voilà comme on dit les cochons
beaucoup sur ce match pour voir là
parfait match préparer sérieusement
pendant la semaine et puis
voilà sur le match effectivement on
lâche un peu à la fin les gars ont tout
donné mais peut-être qu'en face il avait
effectivement plus envie du fait du
maintien acquis qui se profilait
ministère était au dessus ou pas thomas
non je pense qu'on est des équipes sont
à peu près du même niveau on a à peu
près la même façon de jouer maintenant
il y avait peut-être un peu plus de
banques nous du coup à l'arrivée sur la
fin du match c'est ce qui a fait la
différence
guillaume payen c'est vous termine sur
une mauvaise note est ce que c'est
embêtant
voilà pour la suite si jamais plaisant
de perdre mais on n'est pas convaincu
comme on dit souvent joueur n'est pas
meilleur ou moins bon avec 7 victoires 7
défaites on apprend même niveau voilà on
prépare la saison prochaine depuis un
petit moment déjà et effectivement ça
fait toujours plaisir les derniers
matches c'est toujours un moment
particulier serre que tu finis forcément
et du genre car est calé les joueurs qui
vont déménager etc soit un petit moment
que tu aimes bien finir en beauté
ils souhaitent plusieurs années comme tu
sais mais quel con on est con et au club
on a eu des très belle fin de saison en
d avec des victoires à l'extérieur
hier c c'est pas une bonne fin de saison
puisque vous comme vraiment on a fait
une belle partie va être une belle
partie de rugby avec aussi bien des
adversaires que nous l'envient de jouer
un match très propre
bon arbitrage on finit sur un beau match
quand même après on n'a pas le résultat
qu'on voulait on voulait gagner c'est
pas grave alors au classement je le
disais vous terminiez à l'a20 à la 7e
place du classement jérémy est ce que
vous êtes satisfait non parce qu en
dernier avec tesla pas être satisfait de
finir en corse en milieu de tableau en
plus en début de saison c'était données
avec les gars on s'était on s'était rien
passé dit voilà on va essayer
d'accrocher au moins au moins une place
qualificative et
et voilà on termine dans le ventre mou
du championnat c'est pas forcément
satisfaisant en terme de compétition
thomas est ce que vous sentez une
amélioration par rapport à la saison
dernière où vous avez lutté pour le
maintien jusqu'à la dernière journée
alors que là cette fois ci le maintien
était acquis
finalement assez rapidement bah il ya eu
clairement une évolution en effet par
rapport à ça c'est à dire que l'année
dernière jusqu'à dernière journée on
savait pas si on allait se maintenir
là on l'assuré assez rapidement sur des
matchs importants à l'extérieur contre
des concurrents directs donc l'après
matic a peut-être venu de là aussi c'est
qu'on sait très vite maintenu on a très
vite eu aussi des équipes de tête de
poule qui sont détachés nous ont fait
rêver de retrouver dans ce moment ventre
mou ou après du coup l'enjeu était
peut-être moins sur le résultat mais
plus sur les prestations
donc on s'est concentré sur notre rugby
sur notre jeu et peut être un peu moins
son classement alors vous avez concédé
12 défaites
c'était pas trop pour espérer mieux
cette saison c'était pas trop pour
espérer os x comme formule
j'aime bien je sais pas ce qu'on espère
espère toujours faire à notre niveau on
est pas un et panther 14 à viser la
coupe d'europe où le maintien ou ceci ou
cela d'où notre niveau c'est chaque
dimanche qu'un match est fausse et de le
gagner et faut essayer surtout de faire
des bons matches et d'être content de
soi à la fin on a quand même sur les 18
matchs de la saison oui effectivement 12
défaites c'est toujours trop pour autant
on est l'équipe qui a gagné plus de
bonus de poule beaucoup de bonus
défensif parce que ben on a bouffé
retrouve avec des situations de match où
on a perdu à la seconde
on n'a pas réussi à gagner la guerre
secondes et on était tous vents et cloud
c'est ce qui compte c'est à dire que
perdre un match de 40 points ou ou
bazeilles jusqu'à la 80e minute c'est
pas la même chose et cette saison on a
quasiment batailler jusqu'à la seconde
sortent tous les matches et ça c'était
bien parce que ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas et la semaine d'avant c'était pas
le cas il ya des matches qu'on on
pouvait pas tenir dès la mi temps on
était ont été largués cette année on a
existé qu'à trois minutes quasiment à
tous les matchs et ça c'est un vrai
progrès justement tu vas vous allez vous
appuyez sur quoi la saison prochaine
quel secteur de jeu où il faudra
continuer notre travail donc nous soit
un rugby de mouvement avec des jeunes
issus du club donc on garde cette
philosophie en espérant toujours
récupérer
nos juniors qui vont monter on a
emmagasiné pas mal d'expérience cette
année donc vu que 50 des jeunes moi
c'est important on repart sur ce
collectif sur ses bases pour avoir un
peut-être un peu plus d'ambition
sportive du coup la saison prochaine il
va y avoir un gros recrutement où ça va
être essentiellement des jeunes du cru
alors je reprends autre que toi bien
dire c'est la continuité sa politique du
club s'est pas séparé de mano c'est pas
nouveau le recrutement si on a toujours
ce qu'on dit toujours le recrutement
c'est que maximum de joueurs continuent
à jouer parce que c'est pas le cas dans
tous les clubs et joueurs carette et à
des joueurs et joueurs qui sont en
mutation professionnelle etc
et puis surtout c'est intégrer des
jeunes avant clairement au rugby le
recrutement il sera interne
ils sont en interne beaucoup beaucoup de
clubs et c'est tant mieux donc on a les
juniors qu'on joue avec nous afin de
saison et derniers matchs et qui ont
fait qu'ils ont prouvé les très belles
choses que mal bossé avec avec leur
staff tout au long de la saison et donc
on espère qu'ils vont intégrer
eh ben c'est un vrai recrutement en
interne l'objectif l'année prochaine ça
sera quoi
l'objectif ça va être ma toujours garder
la même qualité de jeu même état
d'esprit est allé chercher une première
partie de classement où les réaliser
peut-être une saison comme versailles
l'a réalisé c'est un art on n'a pas les
mêmes les mêmes moyens qu'on n'a pas non
plus les mêmes ambitions forcément mais
en tout cas oui c'est d'avoir plus de
victoires et c'est de mettre un peu
d'engouement autour des prestations de
groupes neuf groupes seniors se serait
pendu
jérémy vous allez suivre c'est un petit
peu de loin qu'est ce que vous espérez
pour
vous désormais ex-coéquipier à le
meilleur forcément qu'ils fassent une
super saison
éventuellement envisager un championnat
de france et pourquoi pas une montée
mais voilà après comme les cochons dit
il faut être fait fort être réaliste
faut continuer à construire le groupe
voilà il ya un bon groupe avec des
bonnes valeurs
c'est important donc je pense quoi il
faut miser sur la continuité du monte
c'est possible pourquoi pas ça sera à
nous la fin merci à vous d'être passé
sur ce plateau se donnent rendez vous en
septembre pour le début de la saison et
pourquoi pas pour une saison historique
pour le sky rugby une dernière
information rugby s'est terminé
également pour les poules de promotion
honneur montigny le bretonneux termine
par une défaite sur le fil 15 à 12 sur
le teint de noisy le grand
une contre-performance qui n'aura pas de
lourdes conséquences au classement
lésigny montain termine 3e de la poule
avec 57 points à 11 points du leader
honni après le rugby du football avec le
championnat de régionale 3 trappes n'a
pu faire mieux que match nul 2 partout
sur le terrain de saint-ouen-l'aumône ce
qu'en finale donc de bain de partout ce
huitième nul de la saison n'arrange pas
les affaires des trappistes qui aurait
pu passer devant leur adversaire du jour
en cas de succès le strap restent
troisièmes en embuscade à deux points de
la première place
direction maintenant le championnat de
d1 de district ont joué ce week-end la
19e journée six matchs étaient au
programme
sartrouville s'impose 2 à 1 face à
guyancourt moreau pas réalise le carton
de cette journée en battant ou sur le
score de 5 à 1
marly le roi 2000 plaisir 2 à 0 même
score pour le ch est née face aux
montois match nul entre montées sont en
carrière grésillons enfin gargenville
s'impose contre hardy hardricourt sur la
plus petite des marges 1 0
le championnat est toujours dominé par
où ils malgré sa défaite
football toujours mais cette fois ci
chez les jeunes le centre technique
national de clairefontaine a accueilli
ce samedi la 1re étape qualificative de
la danone nations cup une grande
compétition mondiale réservé aux filles
et aux garçons de 10 à 12 ans parmi les
équipes engagées des structures
yvelinoise comme trappe et du en cours
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
un montage de xavier jaillard une
journée exceptionnelle pour 1600 enfants
les jeunes footballeurs âgés de 10 à 12
en plus jouer ce samedi 13 avril sur les
terrains d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine
à l'occasion de la danone nations cup
leurs coupes du monde à eux c'est une
vraie compétition qui existe donc depuis
plus de 20 ans
elle a été créée par notre président
après la coupe du monde 98 pour
permettre aux enfants de réaliser leur
rêve le rêve étant de pouvoir jouer
comme les grands joueurs de football sur
des terrains connus
si certaines équipes sont venues
profiter du panorama d'autres au
contraire sont venus pour performer sur
la compétition c'est le cas de leur
strip voir où l évolution des gamins
après pour les gamins pouvoir se situer
par rapport à d'autres d'autres clubs et
notamment des clubs le plus prestigieux
que lui est un peu le astra par exemple
l'équipe de bus en cours est également
venu avec des joueurs sur les terrains
de clairefontaine même si les féminines
sont repartis avec quatre défaites en
quatre matches dans leurs valises
l'objectif de la journée est atteint
c'est exceptionnel puisque déjà l'année
dernière en poupe
on a on n'est pas venu et ça libe c'est
déjà bien d'être là qu'on perd 3 gagne
au moins ça fait plaisir
jouer à clairefontaine un endroit qui
est normalement réservé uniquement aux
halles et l'italie qui ont toutes les
équipes de france
c'est une expérience unique dont elles
vont se rappeler je pense aux toute leur
vie après cette journée aucune équipe
yvelinoise n'est parvenue à se qualifier
pour la grande finale nationale qui se
disputera le 22 juin prochain à paris du
baseball à présent dans le championnat
de division 1 les cougars se reprennent
ils se sont imposés lors de leurs deux
matchs contre eux mais ce week-end ils
emportent dans la première partie 11 à 7
et 7 assists dans le second match
une victoire qui permet donc aux minimes
montain de remonter à la deuxième place
de la poule b juste derrière les
templiers de sénart prochain match
dimanche prochain sur le terrain du pluc
de paris foot us maintenant victoire sur
le fil pour les templiers d'elancourt
dans le championnat de 2e division
ils se sont imposés ce week-end contre
les pionniers de touraine à l'extérieur
sur le score de 15 à 14
une équipe qu'ils avaient déjà battus
d'un petit point lors du premier match
cette victoire leur permet de rester
leaders de leur poule de la conférence
nord nous allons maintenant à parler de
d'échec ce d'elancourt qui recevait
asnières ce dimanche lors de la dernière
journée du championnat de n 4 et les
chocs selon facilement emporté sur le
score fleuve de 11 à 4 les résumé du
match
un montage 2eme jana
match de fin de saison au gymnase
chastagner les chocs ce dell en coiffe
ronde ce dimanche 14 avril asnières pour
la dernière journée du championnat de
nationale 4 après une entame de match
convaincante ponctuée par deux buts les
visiteurs reviennent au score juste
avant la mi-temps 2 à 1 à la pause
on n'a pas trop joué on n'a pas trop
forcé on a voulu on n'a pas vraiment
joué en fait clairement on à suzhou et
ferment pas de pression particulière on
savait qu'on était quand on rester en
nationale iv c'était un match de
classement
je pense qu'on la prenne un peu en
dilettante au retour des vestiaires les
visiteurs égalisent rapidement à
détonateur pour elle en cours
les vagues offensives élan courtoise
déferlent sur le but d'asnières le chox
l'emportent finalement assez facilement
11 à 4 le deuxième plus gros score de la
saison pour les locaux deuxième mi temps
voilà dès qu'on a commencé à jouer ça
allait mieux quoi le score reflète comme
le but c'était de mettre au maximum se
faire plaisir parce qu'il ya deux de nos
joueurs qui s'en vont quand même dans
dans d'autres clubs pour évoluer à plus
haut niveau mais donc le but c'était de
se faire plaisir entre nous et marquer
le maximum de buts elancourt tam cette
saison en milieu de tableau à la 5e
place de la poule sur huit équipes
engagées à un petit peu décevant l'année
dernière la finale au même niveau on
pensait au moins jouer les play off
cette année on a eu quelques petits
problèmes à l'aîné des naissances ou
pouvait pas gérer ça son papa on est
tous heureux qu'ils soient pas mes deux
meilleurs attaquants sont pas là
objectif la saison prochaine revenir en
nationale 3 après être descendu de cette
division en 2017
on va maintenant parler d'un sport
cousin du roller hockey le floorball ce
sport pratiqué principalement dans les
pays du nord est arrivé en 2015 à but
pour nous parler de cette discipline et
du club nous recevons l'entraîneur
sébastien le fauche et sandra bravard
joueuses de l'équipe et le gardien
valérian thomas bonsoir alors avant de
parler du formol
est ce qu'on peut dire que le roller
hockey et cousin du floorball oui on
peut dire il ya des similitudes avec le
roller hockey et le hockey sur glace et
d'autres types de hockey après c'est
vrai qu'il ya certaines règles qui sont
assez différentes et même dans par
exemple les protections aussi c'est
assez différent aux flambeaux par
exemple on est moins protégé dans le
sens où les charges sont plus sont plus
sévèrement punis là en rollers ok on
vous voit même hockey sur glace
on a droit à un peu plus de charge mais
également les des équipements comme
comme les palais sont un peu plus lourd
donc on se prend empalé sur la jambe
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu plus mal
qu'une balle de flashball par exemple
pour vous montrer le matériel après mais
après c'est vrai que bon ça reste ça
reste les mêmes règles il ya cinq
joueurs sur le terrain plus un gardien
dans chaque équipe
le les tailles des buts sont à peu près
similaires
les stratégies sont les mêmes trois
attaquants de deux défenseurs sont très
bavards
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un
petit peu pourquoi vous avez lancé cet
atelier enfin ce sport à pic alors ça
vient du président au fait qui a
pratiqué en fait le floorball lorsqu'il
affaire assez méfiant suède
donc quand il est mis en france il a
voulu continuer à faire ce sport donc il
était d'abord dans le nord et quand il
est arrivé en région parisienne donc à
guyancourt justement il
vous lui en fait perpétuer en fait ce
sport localement et elle faire connaître
est ce que ça fonctionne bien
oui très bien donc on a de plus en plus
de joueurs chaque année généralement
c'est des gens qui ont découvert ce
sport à l'étranger j'avoue j'ai
découvert ce sport au canada là qu'ils
ont découvert aussi en suisse
après c'est un sport qui est très
accessible c'est à dire que là on est
fort ball là on voit des images donc on
est en basket
donc tout le monde à c'était cet
équipement le club prête aussi la crosse
et des lunettes de protection aux
besoins voilà pour quelqu'un qui veut
démarrer un sport qui est assez physique
ça demande un peu de condition quelqu'un
qui aime courir qui aiment les
accélérations et qui a envie de toucher
de près la technicité d'un jeu de balle
c'est vraiment très intéressant est ce
qu'il ya de plus en plus d'adhérents à
buc basse est en progression on a dit
que le club fondé en 2015 donc ça ça
monte chaque année après on a un noyau
dur le niveau progresse il y avait moi
j'observe une bonne progression sur sur
le niveau des joueurs
on est encore engagé cette année en
championnat la section reste aux loisirs
mais on a la possibilité de au site
s'exprimer sur les terrains au niveau
compétitif et pourquoi vous vous êtes
lancé vous justement alors là moi ça
rejoint un peu l'expérience du du
président moi j'ai travaillé en suède il
ya quelques années j'ai découvert le
sport au travail c'était vraiment le
l'activité numéro un le sport numéro 1
accessible pour tout le monde tu revenir
à paris j'ai joué j'ai joué de suite moi
à paris pendant pendant une dizaine
d'années avant de trouver quelque chose
à proximité de chez moi sandra vous êtes
l'une des seules féminines du club
pourquoi oui alors la ligne 4 féminines
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est de faire
connaître ce sport en fait je pense que
les les personnes ont peut-être peur de
l'intensité physique ça fait peur aux
filles le floorball c'est ça c'est ça je
pense que c'est le contact qui fait peur
alors qu'au contraire c'est un sport
sans contact parce qu'à la différence
des autres formes de hockey bas on voit
déjà sur nous on n'a pas de protection
etc dans les règles du jeu justement
d'être sans contact de pas porter de
charges et s'il ya contact il ya faute
donc bien sûr est-ce qu'on devient
facilement accro à ce support oui
pourquoi vous dites oui alors
personnellement j'avais débuté puisque
j'avais droit à des séances d'essai et
effectivement c'est un sport qui mêle
la l'endurance on court beaucoup faut
être faut être assez endurant on peut
vite s'essouffler si on est passé près
il faut être fou être technique avec une
crosse faut savoir est habile avec c'est
demain mélangez le tout mélangé le tout
du coup c'est super stimulant et
d'autant plus que entre les attaquants
les défenseurs des gardiens c'est pas le
même style de jeu
mais à la fin du coup on trouve toujours
son poste de prédilection toujours quoi
faire et puis la seule chose qu'on a
envie de dire c'est vivement la dalle à
la prochaine séance
comment on fait pour se lancer justement
il faut acheter du matériel alors
justement un casque c'est bien ça ça
c'est ça c'est mon casque personnel mais
effectivement comme disait sébastien le
matériel est fourni en général les les
joueurs de champ ils ont juste besoin
d'une crosse après ils utilisent pour
les entraînements un équipement de sport
basique un tee shirt un short et des
baskets et après effectivement vu pour
les crocs comme pour les équipements de
gardien on a envie d'avoir son propre
son propre équipement et c'est pour ça
qu'on a investi petit à petit ça coûte
cher ou par une crosse par exemple alors
une crosse depuis un an depuis peu il ya
un grand une grande enseigne de sport
qui vend ce type de matériel en marque
propre donc cédé des prix comme toutes
les autres activités sportives
on va dire un prix plancher après une
cinquantaine d'euros on a une crosse de
gros calibre résistante et ça peut aller
jusqu'à 150 euros
sandra vous faites également des
compétitions quel est le prochain rendez
vous pour le club
alors notre club a fait de très bons
résultats cette année
donc on a une équipe très mixte au club
donc la prochaine échéance ce sont les
play-offs à brest
donc vous jouer avec les garçons alors
pas cette année moi je me réserve pour
le féminin et c'est vrai que sur la
dynamique on va dire du féminin il ya un
championnat dédié qui continue à faire
la promotion pour avoir de plus en plus
d' équipe est en open féminin à tour au
mois de juin et le championnat redémarre
au mois de septembre
mais comment on fait pour vous rejoindre
ça se passe comment alors tout le monde
à venir tester justement fleurs vol abus
qu on a justement des portes ouvertes
pendant tout le mois de juin
donc ça se passe le mercredi soir à
19h45 au gymnase du prés saint-jean à
buc à buc
merci à tous les trois devaient être
passées sur ce plateau on vous souhaite
d'avoir le plus d'abonnés à la rentrée
prochaine merci beaucoup
du breakdance à présent une compétition
solidaire et amical était organisé ce
dimanche à la maison de l'environnement
de magny les hameaux les dizaines de
sportifs du secteur se sont affrontés
dans des battles de moins de 2 minutes
sous l'oeil des juges mais l'essentiel
était ailleurs les organisateurs
proposent au public de payer leur place
en donnant des denrées alimentaires on
écoute l'un des organisateurs ils vont
être impliqués dans l'événement et donc
du coup ramener des denrées alimentaires
qui va permettre aussi de d d d autres
donc on a le côté artistique ont la cote
et solidarité
mais intergénérationnel donc c'était
vraiment un enjeu qu'il fallait tester
on l'a fait ça marche
le breakdance devrait faire son
apparition aux jo de 2024 à paris le
comité international olympique a validé
ce choix à fin mars
cette discipline qui fera partie des
quatre sports additionnel doit
maintenant être soumise à la session du
cio qui réunira en juin les mais les
responsables qu'en pensent les
pratiquants nous leur avons posé la
question je dirais c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué ça dépend vraiment comment
comment c'est fait par qui s'est jugé
voilà compliqué contre je trouve que
c'est une belle avancée pour le
breakdance parce qu'on n'entende est
reconnue donc je pense que ça peut nous
ouvrir des portes
bon maintenant le problème il toujours
mais il faut voir de quelle manière il
va être encadré c'est quand même quelque
chose de bien qu'on puisse c'est que le
hip hop plus évolué et qui deviennent
vraiment reconnus parce que je sais
qu'avant ben c'était pas du tout le cas
on traiter avec un comme des moins que
rien alors que manon et c'est vraiment
reconnue et on reconnaît vraiment le hip
hop comme quelque chose depuis évité
mois du golfe à présent c'était une
première à mantes-la-jolie la ville a
accueilli le mondial du golf pendant
trois jours plus de 100 exposants sont
venus pour présenter leur produit
golfique
au total dix mille personnes sont venues
sur le site certains ont notamment pu
tester les clubs sur un practice
pourquoi les yvelines ont-elles
accueilli un tel événement les réponses
avec l'un des organisateurs
charles-henri bacheliers au micro de
notre journaliste patrick jacques de
dixmude le département des yvelines est
le premier département golfique de
france ya 26 18 trous il ya trente
licenciés département où s'est tenu sur
doc nationale la ryder cup et également
parce qu'il ya ce site de l'île l'aumône
qui est absolument magnifique qui
ressemble au golf qui est
d'une il donc entouré de l'eau c'est la
scène qui passe de chaque côté c'est
vers ces boisés et donc ça ressemble au
golf un mot de cyclisme à présent la 28e
édition de l'agent racines étaient
organisées ce week-end au départ de
saint rémy les chevreuse plus de cinq
mille sportifs ont bravé le froid cette
année pour participer à cette course
cyclotouriste à travers les yvelines au
programme neuf parcours vtt de 10 à 120
km et trois tracés route de 40 à 120 km
les parcours pour les enfants étaient
également organisées en écoute les
réactions au micro de tv 78 a toujours à
jean racine c'est son organisation elle
est unique c'est une association une
collectivité qui organise un événement
convivial avant tout c'est pas un
événement organisé par notre presse qui
cherchent à faire du bénéfice est un
événement qui organisait pour faire
plaisir et faire du vélo et mettre les
gens au sport ça participe au
rayonnement de notre ville au
rayonnement de notre territoire la
vallée de chevreuse et je pense que tous
les participants de la région de la
région ile-de-france mais même au delà
maintenant et bien au delà rencontrer
des bretons hier dès les gens de toutes
les régions de france
cette fête du vélo francilien va devenir
une fête de la fête du vélo national je
pense très vite
si vous avez raté l'agent vacin ce
week-end une compétition cycliste est
programmée à montigny le bretonneux
le club local organise sa 4e édition de
la course de pâques dans les rues de la
commune
le circuit empruntera l'avenue du parc
la venue des prix l'avenue du général
leclerc et l'avenue nicolas à bout
environ 150 kw hors de toute la région
ile de france ont participé à cette
compétition le départ des catégories d3
et d4 est programmé à 8 heures la course
des des uns et des deux partira à 10
heures et on termine pas en rendez-vous
rugby et match capital pour plaisir en
fédérale 2 les plaisirs aux halles à
vide pour le maintien reçoivent le havre
un adversaire direct pour la dernière
journée de la saison la rencontre est
programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade robert barran si vous voulez les
soutenir l'entrée est libre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve le lundi 29
avril pour un nouveau magazine d'ici là
passez une excellente semaine sportive
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il